Speaker 1: . Let's go next to where do we
want to go?
How about Isaac from Wyoming.
Isaac, you're on the air.
Isaac from Wyoming, you're on the air.
And Isaac is gone.
That's too bad, it was looking forward to
speaking to a caller from Wyoming.
Let's go next to Frumpies from Chicago.
Frumpies, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: And can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I'm right here.
Speaker 2: OK, David, good to hear you doing
good.
So I'm wondering, like with the with Biden
not going forward with the public option,
I'm wondering what the strategy is there,
because I know a lot of other people voted
for him on that.
And I'm wondering why he just decided to go
with, like, lowering these deductibles.
I think a public option was even part of Obamacare's
initial proposal before it got cut.
So what's the strategy?
Speaker 1: I don't know.
I wish I could tell you.
And, you know, it's not like I'm going to
be defending things that I don't think should
be defended.
I don't I don't know the answer to that.
And is it part of some bigger strategy as
a party?
I don't know.
And we we you know, I think that being four
months in, as I said earlier, only four months
into the presidency, I'm still sort of open
and waiting and seeing what the full trajectory
is going to be.
But I just don't have an answer.
And, you know, I'm not the defender of everything
Biden does, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: I gotcha.
I try and I try to defend a lot of things
Biden does, but it's really hard now.
But like, yeah, I was thinking, at least rhetorically,
you could go with like this was Obama's thing
and all this.
And so it was just weird.
OK, that's it for me.
My girlfriend loves you, by the way, so you
do OK.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Very nice.
Nice phone call.
OK.
Why don't we go next to Brett from Indiana.
Brett, you were on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Gosh, I have to admit, I'm actually super
nervous talking to you right now.
Speaker 1: You're doing great already.
I can tell you're going to be great.
Speaker 2: So I'm not going to lie.
I'm super politically active.
And I wish I could ask you 20 questions, but
I know we're on a limited amount of time.
Right.
So I wanted to ask you how you felt about
this.
So there's this debate of D.C. and Puerto
Rico statehood.
Yep.
From D.C.
There's no debate.
Personally, I think it needs statehood at
this point.
I mean, it's for another discussion.
But Puerto Rico to me is a little bit more
complicated because there's people who think,
oh, it's just colonizers wanting to just add
it to the United States.
And one concern I have about it is basically
there was a referendum vote about whether
they should become independent or become a
state.
And it was fifty two to forty eight percent.
Right.
And I'm just I'm just concerned about that
number because my thing is I think that number
is way too low.
It's not overwhelming.
Speaker 1: It's not overwhelming.
And there are people who say it should have
been you know, it should have a 60 percent
threshold or more.
I mean, let's go through it piece by piece.
It is without question that the D.C. and Puerto
Rico situations are not the same.
There's no question now you can take the position
that both should be states, probably for slightly
different reasons.
But there's no question that the D.C. and
Puerto Rico situations are different.
Now, one of the differences is that D.C. residents
are much more overwhelmingly in support of
being a state than Puerto Rican residents
are.
And so what you're talking about is sort of
the desire of the population and their ability
to to to to self determine.
I think that it's morally right to offer both
the opportunity to be states and certainly
the people that are there can have a say in
that.
But I agree that they're not the same situation.
Speaker 2: Right.
And one more question and then I'll just hit
the road for you.
So I was wondering, how do you feel about
education in this country?
Because I've always argued strongly that we
should expand upon it because I'm in the National
Guard and the unit I go to once a month for
drill.
Basically, it's in this small country town
in Indiana.
And I'm just going to put it plainly, the
high school there, it looks like crap.
Yeah.
And like I've always argued, there's this
inequality of education funding, you know,
small country towns, they don't get a lot
of they don't get a lot of money from the
state compared to like big city schools.
And then, you know, schools like, you know,
in places like I don't want to call it the
ghetto.
That be rude.
I would call it.
Rather, not very wealthy areas as much as
an state, and I was just wondering, how do
you feel we should expand upon education in
this country?
Because council presidency certainly made
me realize I feel like we have to work on
education.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, I mean, the educational system, this is
such a big topic.
It has to be completely rethought and reformed.
But a couple of things are, number one, a
lot of this has to do with how states are
run and you have states that pride themselves
on.
We have lower no income tax or we have very
low property taxes or whatever.
And then you get schools that are equivalent
to to the amount of low tax that the states
sort of brag about.
You have state boards of education, including,
for example, in Texas, where they are just
destroying the curriculum.
And you're not even getting a shot based on
what these boards of education are are doing.
So one piece is at the state level.
Federal education policy is a really tough
thing.
And how do you do federal policy for a country
of three hundred and thirty one million people?
It's a really difficult question to answer
and and a very complex one.
But part of it is we've had long strings of
incompetent people in federal education leadership.
I mean, just look at under Trump Betsy Devise.
She had no business being in that position
whatsoever.
And so we you know, we can talk about specific
reforms, but you've got to completely go back
to the drawing board with the way that a lot
of the where the funding comes from, how funding
is distributed, what are the metrics that
are used for evaluating schools and teachers?
What is done as a result of those metrics?
The system is so broken, as you seem to be
pointing out.
Speaker 2: Yes, I agree.
And, you know, there are you know, I speak
Spanish and I'm learning French and German
and like basically I went to Madrid and I
was really amazed as to how many, you know,
many people they spoke French or than some
of them spoke other languages because they
literally learned since elementary school,
basically.
Right.
Language, no.
Well, the
Speaker 1: real issue, if you look globally,
the surprising thing is how few people in
the United States speak two languages.
That's really the surprising thing globally.
But to many Americans, it's surprising to
see that so many people in other countries
do speak two languages.
It's completely backwards, Brett.
Speaker 2: It is, and yeah, and so I just
I just really hope with Biden's presidency,
something can get done because I'll say one
thing.
I am pretty disgusted with Joe Manchin and
Kirstyn sentiments here right now, because
I feel like there are work.
I feel like they're wolves in sheep's clothing.
Speaker 1: Listen, they're there with us on
a lot of stuff, but they're not with us on
enough stuff that it's a big, big concern.
But I appreciate the call.
Thank you for your service.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I appreciate it.
And by the way, fun fact.
I just drove past Columbus, Indiana, where
Mike Pence is from there.
What they wanted to put up a statue.
And then I just saw a sign where they just
said Vice President Pence is from here, in
fact.
Speaker 1: All right, Bret, thank you.
Appreciate that.
That latest breaking news and hope to hear
from you again of really close to a perfect
phone call, my friends.
That is all the time.
I have four calls today.
Apologies if I didn't get to you.
And I will hope to hear from
you
on
the next one